hey what's up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to the setup tour project so
this is a project to create the largest
ever collaborative setup tour video on
youtube setup tours are a little bit
more than just what's on your desk it
kind of surrounds the whole workspace
and how you use that workspace for your
workflow and getting things done it's
what you sit down at every day and do
things that a lot of you might already
know i moved recently and one of the
types of videos that i watched a lot and
i moved in was set up tour videos and uh
part of the reason why i realized i love
watching setup tour videos so much i
didn't give a thumbs up on this video if
you agree is that you actually learn
things from other people's setups to
bring back to your own setup my setup
back here actually changes all the time
it almost never stays the same for more
than about a week or two and that's
because i'm constantly getting ideas
from outside sources from other articles
from other youtube videos and from other
people's setups i'm sure there are other
people out there just like me who are
constantly changing and tweaking their
setup just to fit them exactly perfectly
even though it never stays the same for
very long so here's how to become part
of this awesome project you
make a little mini setup tour about a 10
to 20 second video showcasing what is
interesting or unique about your setup
something that someone can learn from
your setup bring your camera way back so
give a wide angle view of everything and
just talk about what that unique thing
is so it might be your laptop or your
monitor setup or your desktop or your
desk or your draws or your speakers or
your cable management tricks whatever it
is be sure to get that on video and show
it in that 10 to 20 second video upload
your noteworthy setup to youtube and
post it as a video response to this
video if you don't have a youtube
account you can send it to that email
address in the description below the
like button on this video and there are
some large file sending sites so there's
a site called yousendit.com that'll
allow you send up to 50 megabytes of a
video for free if you do submit via
email though be sure to include
some link like a youtube or something
you want me to shout out because
everyone who submits via youtube will be
getting a shout out so for the rest of
the week i will be collecting and
watching and compiling all of these into
one
massive setup tour video that will
hopefully be able to help the most
amount of people possible so if you want
to see these sorts of videos make sure
you share this video share this on
twitter share this on facebook on google
plus and get the word out to anyone who
likes watching setup tour videos so go
ahead and submit your video and brace
yourself for a setup tour of epic
proportions including my own which will
be in that video and that should come
out at the end of this weekend either
way looking forward to making that
looking forward to seeing you guys
setups and looking forward to showing
you guys the half of the desk that you
guys haven't seen here yet either way
thanks for watching and i'll talk to you
guys in the next video
peace
[Music]
you